c'est la fin d'une longue épreuve pour
230 migrants dont 57 enfants à bord de
ce bateau
ils ont tous été rescapés d'embarcation
de fortune en Méditerranée au large de
la Libye ils sont par la suite restés
trois semaines sur le haut shinking dans
ses espaces restreints mais impossible
d'accoster en Italie c'est finalement en
France à Toulon qu'ils ont pu mettre un
pied à terre
ils ont été transférés en autobus vers
un centre de vacances transformé en
centre d'accueil dans les chambres ils
ont déjà tout un kit nourriture qui les
attend qui permet justement de pouvoir
les nourrir pendant 24 heures ils sont
originaires de nombreux pays tels que la
Libye le Tchad le Nigéria le soudain
chaque demande d'asile sera étudié au
cas par cas effectivement il y a un
contrôle important de la part de la
police aux frontières pour
l'identification des personnes l'état
civil la nationalité est-ce qu'ils sont
mineurs ou majeurs le ministre de
l'Intérieur n'a pas marché ses mots en
vers l'Italie Italie a été très
inhumaine dans cette situation les
autorités italiennes ont été par
ailleurs non professionnel elles ont
laissé pendant 20 jours sans décision ce
bateau ce geste aura des conséquences la
France contre serrer le contrôle de ses
frontières affirme-t-il pour sa part la
chef du parti d'extrême droite Marine Le
Pen réclame le renvoie de ces migrants
il faut que ces navires qui mettent en
sécurité migrants qu'il récupère en mer
les ramènent à leur port de départ la
première ministre italienne Georgia
miloni a dénoncé la réaction française
son pays a accueilli cette année près de
90 000 migrants
pour l'instant 11 pays européens ont
accepté de collaborer avec la France
pour accueillir les migrants dont la
demande d'asile sera acceptée ici
Marie-Isabelle Rochon Radio-Canada
Montréal